après la haute couture c'est la saison
du prêt-à-porter avec les salons qui se
tiennent en ce moment à la porte de
versailles le salon who's next met lui
l'accent sur la mode des jeunes et ces
nouvelles tendances et cette année c'est
la rue qui a la cote
le streetwear comme on dit partie des
états unis au départ limité aux amateurs
de rap
cette mode déferle sur l'europe et vise
une clientèle beaucoup plus large
reportage jean laurent sera et olivier
kg est inclus une reconnaissance qui a
tendance musicale de rentes et non et de
vêtements de streetwear réservé aux
rappeurs skate boarder et jeunes
quittent de brancher le streetwear quand
un des esprits de la rue s'adoucissent
assagi s'adapte à tous
excentré qu'elle rebelles hier +12
aujourd'hui la tendance fils marché où
le provoque
business is business aux excentricités
tue le marché
paraît-il pour moi c'est sûr les jeunes
s'identifient souvent aux autres mais
aujourd'hui ils ne veulent plus porter
de vêtements trop marqué trop
excentrique l'acte ii d'avril d'exclus
ils ont un style plus discret il mélange
les gens c'est une tendance plus sage
plus calme qu'avant ça c'est sûr
le message est passé les créateurs l'ont
compris le bagagiste sand sonic entre
dans la danse et lance sa collection
jungle urbaine
la cible les 15 25 ans nouveau marché
pour de nouveaux débouchés la aux
futures pointent également sonné
azzaro habile et damoiselles fille de
clients haut de gamme
ma génération j'ai toujours regretté de
pas voir des gens dans la rue a mis en
avant
j'ai trouvé ça me serait très dommage on
est spécialisé dans le soir ce départ
azzaro aidant les choses très très
glamour dans les rangs bollywoodienne on
voudrait aligner les filles de nos
clientes
on voudrait renouveler là dessus il
renouvelle à la génération le streetwear
version excentrique a lancé une tendance
aujourd'hui pour des raisons
commerciales les créateurs cible large
pour tout le monde
l'esprit de la rue s'oriente de plus en
plus vers le vêtements de tous les jours
le passe partout